i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to are
people who have secret service stand
around them um so it's it's part of the
process
president biden trying to downplay and
dismiss far-left protesters targeting
moderate democratic senators kirsten
cinema and joe manchin the progressive
activists taking things to a whole new
level and following cinema into a
bathroom while demanding she back the
president's agenda
we need a buildback better plan right
now
we need solutions to build that better
plan we knocked on doors for you to get
you elected and just how we got you
elected we can get you out of office if
you don't support what you promised us
ana swarm of protesters made their
voices heard outside joe manchin's
houseboat insisting he raised taxes on
wealthy americans
senator this is an investment this is
not giving out money this is not
spending this is investing and this is
building the state that we both love
that's why we're both here fighting for
our people
plus president biden's singling out
those two moderates for not getting on
board and backing trillions in new
spending
i've been able to close the deal on 99
of my party
two
two people
that's still underway
i need 50 votes
in the senate
i have 48.
well i laid out what i thought it should
be
the
legislation
both the buildback better piece
as well as the infrastructure piece
are things that i wrote
these these these didn't come from
god love them bernie sanders or aoc or
anybody else i wrote them all right
kennedy uh i i just laid i can't stand
phones in bathrooms like in the public
restroom and people are on the phone i i
can't take it if this this what happened
to me i probably would have completely
lost it she was there to teach her class
that she teaches at arizona state
university and gets followed into the
bathroom not by just women but men too
yeah and bryden's like yeah that happens
everybody's part of the process no it is
such a childish and emotionalist tactic
and it's unacceptable you know we saw
this throughout the entire trump
administration how many members of the
administration were shouted out of
restaurants
it's not acceptable if you don't want
someone to do that to you do not do that
to someone else and i really hope that
this steals kirsten cinema's spine i
hope she takes this as some sort of
inspiration to not bend to the loud mob
because she shouldn't she should be
looking at the bottom line she should be
looking at the price tag and her
constituents and what they and the
american people can afford and they
can't afford 3.5 trillion dollars she
knows it joe manchin knows it the entire
democrat party knows it but it reminds
me of when my 16 year old daughter wants
to go to lululemon and buy some stuff
i'm like how much does this stuff cost
and the democrats are acting like my
daughter they want to pretend like it
doesn't cost anything and so aoc and her
squad cohorts are saying
let's not focus on the price tag let's
not focus on how much this stuff costs
like oh yes we absolutely are because i
know you can't afford those lululemon
pants and i sure as heck i'm not going
to buy them for you i don't i think
kirsten cinema seems like the person
kind of person greg who would not be
bullied into changing her behavior
because of being followed him to a
bathroom
you know why she went in there she was
trying to stall them no
um
there's something about the fact that
she is a woman
which is why they did it because there's
an assumption that she wouldn't be
violent which is wrong she should have
been she would have had every a guy
follows her into the bathroom and i
don't know maybe doesn't identify as a
guy but if a guy followed my wife into
the bathroom whatever he identifies with
would soon be a non-life form she had
like i i'm sorry i don't know where
when this happens when is violence
violence is certainly okay in this if
you're in the bathroom and somebody's
filming you that is an assault it's an
assault on you that is your privacy you
should kick that door out hit him right
in the face and that's the end of it and
then if they by the way
in this nation of equity and equality
doesn't matter what the gender is if
somebody's coming into your bathroom if
they don't see it as a problem then you
shouldn't have any problem fighting back
however i say that not understanding the
law
so i'm going to leave that to herald to
tell me if what i just said would
actually be illegal to go out and beat
the crap out of somebody who's filming
you in the in the bathroom uh but biden
is wrong it doesn't happen to everybody
it doesn't happen to it that never
happens to a
leftist if you're a non-liberal
including democrats it can happen to you
in a perfect world yes we could all have
secret service like joe we could all
swim around naked in front of them but
unfortunately a lot of us don't have
secret service or pools
that's true we should get a pool though
for for all of us to share that's
disgusting harold kirsten cinema's
position
was let's pass the bipartisan
infrastructure bill and
she said like biden supports that bill
that was actually the position speaker
pelosi was in
whipping that bill trying to get support
for that bill when president biden came
in on friday afternoon it was like
actually no we want these two things to
be linked forever and i think that there
are a lot of democrats who are probably
hiding behind mansion and cinema hoping
they don't change their minds well i
don't i don't think they're many hiding
i think they're out front first off i
think that i've had people not follow me
in the bathroom but i've had people
harass uh and say things say the most
horrible things and it's part of the
business you got to kind of deal with it
like
uh uh joe manchin that he's got a little
skill humor he got on the back of his
boat and said look i'm with you guys i'm
just not with you on everything two we
have to remember biden beat sanders in
the primary democrats rejected sanders
now we may not like biden's plan but he
he beat sanders and sanders ran on
essentially the six trillion dollar plan
now the i think the majority of the
democratic party is with
biden and is with even pelosi on this
and should say does not want to go down
the path that perhaps aoc and sanders
wants
third thing is i am um
the money side of this i i know we're
going to talk about a little later
jinsaki
i don't think what and we disagree on
this i don't think what biden is saying
when he says this is a zero cost all
he's saying is that it's paid for but
you may not like how no no you may not
like not like how it's paid for you
right
we now have a debt ceiling debate in
this country right now because we pass
things and we never
ever pay for it now you may not like the
fact that taxes are being raised on
people earning i don't like parts of it
but at least at least he has the decency
to say we're going to not add that to on
top of the already 27 trillion worth of
debt in fact i think anytime i think any
time congress votes in the future for
something that they don't raise revenue
for they should automatically put a line
and say we will automatically raise the
debt ceiling for this and not have a
debate about raising it because now if
the republican's not one of the people
then it would be limitless like it would
no no but you would you don't know but
everybody would be on the record voting
for it because if you're a member of
congress and you voted you're saying i'm
going to pass something it's going to
cost 2 trillion a trillion 3 trillion
whatever the number so we're going to
raise the debt ceiling to do it then
you're on the hook for it as opposed to
being able to say jesse did it or or
greg did it or greg and jessie did it or
dana did you guys now going to be the 6
trillion dollar man after he's finished
with this
i want to talk about this woman okay i
actually
went into a bathroom and
followed al gore
but unlike this woman i have standards
and once i realized i was following
someone into the bathroom with a camera
i went up and i turned around
she's 47 years old she is way too old to
be doing something like this she's got a
phd
from george washington university and
she's following people into the bathroom
and screaming at them she's also a
bernie sanders field organizer she
introduced crazy bernie a couple times
she's not some low level person on the
totem pole this is a bernie bro or
bro however you want to refer to it as
and i didn't like her delivery the way
she memorized this it was chanting and
at the end if you watch the whole thing
she's giggling afterwards you're
supposed to ask leading questions
and elicit a response right that's the
way you do this it's called bird docking
it's when you kind of harass
politicians in public places totally
different than what i used to do
the irony is that filming it does not
help her cause like we saw what an
everyday she was sympathizes with cinema
in this situation it's in a purple state
certainly no and full disclosure
i did follow rahm emanuel into the men's
room right and did you stay
he he was in there for a long time he
he uh i had to leave after a while all
right and it is greg greg it's a it's a
felony
arizona to film someone in the bathroom
but what if you push
that that i don't know about you're not
gonna land on somebody give me a ring
things we need to know for the next
block hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else